you're starting to get the idea now I
think the next one's Thursday okay
oh yeah question oh yeah it's gonna
we'll talk about the overall shape once
we've got it okay Thursday what are we
adding on it's four thousand so fifteen
thousand plus four thousand gives us
cumulative frequency of nineteen
thousand which gives me a percentage did
I get the right number zero is it did
you say 76 yeah Sammis percent so seven
and eight so it's gonna be about there
okay and you can keep on going you can
see that the gaps are getting smaller
and smaller why is that by the way why
are the gaps getting smaller and smaller
because I'm adding increasingly small
numbers right so you can see this
getting this curve shape can you
complete it please okay and you'll know
you did it right if your final one for
Wednesday you should know without any
calculations where the data point should
be should be a hundred takers includes
everything okay so go ahead and complete
your data for me get those dots on there
and I'll tell you what to do with them
sorry
some interpretation required yes
Thursday by itself is four thousand we
add that on because cumulative frequency
we add that four thousand on to all of
the previous ones so it's 15 plus 4
which gives you 19,000 is that okay
if you found finished perez dong can you
just call me over I just whatever quick
look yeah cool thank you
yeah sure so what we're doing is this
thing here it's cumulative frequency
percentage so we say okay what
percentage of total sales is this day
the answer is its 8,000 out of the total
which we work out is 25,000 if you add
up every single one of the columns
25,000 in the week so this one will be
8,000 divided by 25,000 what percentage
is that turns out to be 32% so on the
left to throw the right hand side
instead of going up by thousands of
dollars we go up by percentages so it's
like can you see my scale on the right
hand side there 10% 30% etc so the first
thought you can see here that represents
32% and then the next one it's
cumulative not just frequency so I get
bigger and bigger and bigger I keep on
adding each day's sales that make sense
okay can I get your attention again
please so hopefully by now you have most
if not all of these data points the
cumulative frequency percentages graphed
on here's the last part that will
complete the Pareto chart okay we're
going to take these and we're going to
join them up into a a polygon of sorts
okay just straight lines will do so I'm
gonna go from Saturday to Sunday from
Sunday to Thursday Thursday to Tuesday
and you get the I D are you end up at a
hundred percent okay now why do we do
these things they are actually quite
confusing to look at the first time
because you've got this data overlaid on
data about itself and it can be quite
complicated right at the beginning we
said this is all about identifying one
of the most important factors in this
situation they don't have to be days of
the week they could be for example you
know which cities or which suburbs in
Sydney you know have the highest crime
rate you order them right and then you
can say oh I can add up and work
actually the frequency where do the
traffic accidents happen most frequently
which intersection you work out what
percentage you add them up and then you
get this same kind of curve now why does
this matter
okay
the answer is when you're trying to make
decisions often you want to make
decisions in light of what's the most
important when do I put on the most
stuff where do i allocate police or
doctors and nurses or all those kinds of
things right now there's a really nice
way a summary of all this that shares
the same name as this child a predator
it's called the Pareto principle you can
check this up later
and I'd love you to write it down and
I'll give it to you in a really succinct
form I'll try and show it to you on this
data as well the praetor principle is
that 20% of the causes in whatever
situation you look at 20% of the causes
in a situation lead to or result in 80%
that's a zero of the effects you'll
sometimes hear is called the 80/20
effect okay
20% of your clients account for 80% of
your sales 20% of your intersections
account for 80% of your accidents so
what it does is it helps you you know
allocate attention human resources or
physical resources more appropriately in
your situation okay
now the way you can actually read this
off of the graph appropriate color is to
find where is 80% on your cumulative
frequency okay so on mind I can
incidentally not coincidentally my 80%
lines up with my eight over here I just
chose a convenient scale for myself so
if I'm not that a course hopefully is
ringing some bells from things we've
done in the past because it's very much
like how we found the median using our
Oh guys our cumulative frequency polygon
where does this match up to and the
answer is well somewhere in here right
so 20% very roughly speaking of the days
in the week account for 80% of your
sales and you could obviously drill down
to this further maybe instead of just
days you want to know like what time do
people come up they come around lunch
time generally if you've got a food
court and so these kinds of things help
you make better decisions okay so these
Pareto charts is a bit more to unpack
about them but we want you to recognize
what happens when you've got this bar
chart on top of this cumulative
frequency percentage it's so useful it
gets its own name because
quite frequently used see what I did
there questions any questions about this
does it make sense first question for us
right yeah yes absolutely okay this is
the crucial part so I will say it again
I'd sort of I left uh I did a terrible
job step 2
stuff happens okay so um I'll even write
it down for you okay so step one you
place it in order to remember that did
the bar graph the second thing we did
was we calculated this German that okay
so we calculated our total frequency
total sales in this case it might be
total accidents to remember patients
whatever okay you calculate the total
frequency and then you use that total
frequency to work out your cumulative
frequency percentage there's two person
at cumulative frequency and then the
conversion to the percentage so let's do
the cumulative frequency this thing here
right you're doing it in order you
include that days sales patients
frequency and then you add on whatever
all the previous day's are as well so
that's why this one includes the 7000 on
Sunday and the 8000 on Saturday this one
includes the 4000 on Thursday and
everything from the previous day's the
one of my opportunit the 2,000 on
Tuesday and all the previous days that
gives you the cumulative frequency and
in the last step the one you asked about
is take these numbers what are we
divided by each one we divide by the
total frequency right divided by total
frequency and that gives us the
cumulative frequently frequency
percentage make sense divided by total
frequency
eight thousand over 25,000 then fifteen
thousand over 25,000 we're always
comparing to the total sales you know it
ties it by anything
you'll get fifteen thousand divided by
twenty five thousand will be zero point
six which is sixty percent nineteen
thousand divided by twenty five thousand
will be zero point seven six which is 76
visit make sense